[Musik]
2012 drehte sie als erste saudische
regisseurin einen spielfilm
dann ging sie nach hollywood und
verfilmte die biografie von mary shelley
die autorin von frankenstein für ihren
neuen film die perfekte kandidatin kehrt
der haifa al mansur wieder zurück in
ihre heimat
heute ist sie unser perfekte gast und
ich möchte von ihr wissen was sich in
den letzten jahren verändert hat für sie
und im königreich saudi arabien herzlich
willkommen heißen so danke ja die
filmindustrie zu hause in saudi arabien
hat sich seit den dreharbeiten von
waldstatt grundlegend verändert 2012
galt eine strikte geschlechtertrennung
ich durfte draußen auf der straße nicht
zusammen mit der crew gesehen werden
sondern musste aus einem kleinbus heraus
regie führen mit der öffnung des landes
gibt es heute platz für kunst im
öffentlichen raum
ich musste mich beim letzten dreh nicht
mehr verstecken wenn uns tugendwächter
verjagen wollten riefen wir die polizei
dieser rechtliche schutz hat die
dreharbeiten ungemein erleichtert zu
machen ist immer schwer gerade in saudi
arabien wo es keine ausgebaute film
infrastruktur gibt
so fehlen zum beispiel casting agenten
oder location scouts aber es ist
insgesamt viel einfacher geworden
sie sagen gerade die dinge sind im
aufbau begriffen wie sehen sie denn
eigentlich für das casting vorgegangen
für den neuen film das casting war sehr
anspruchsvoll
die hauptdarstellerin milla als errani
ist eine aufstrebende
fernsehschauspielerin
mir gefiel was ich von ihr gesehen hatte
die hauptdarstellerinnen und darsteller
zu finden die noch aber alle anderen
waren laiendarsteller auch das mädchen
das selber spielt es war schwierig
jemanden zu finden der selber
widerspenstigkeit schabernack und humor
umsetzen konnte da jalil ali ist eine
instagram influenza in was immer das
auch sein mag
sie hat viele lustige sketche gemacht
sie war großartig beim vorsprechen hat
sich über sich selbst lustig gemacht
sich nicht versteckt und so die rolle
bekommen
ich bewundere schauspielerinnen die ihr
herz in die hand nehmen und sich zeigen
ganz besonders in saudi arabien wo die
leute sehr konservativ und zurückhaltend
sind
sie war anders der schauspielberuf in
seoul haben sie auch muss eben gesagt es
war schwierig den weiblichen dort zu
finden
grundsätzlich das renomee eines
schauspielers oder einer schauspielerin
welchen stellenwert hat das in saudi
arabien unter der konservativen
islamischen ideologie die lange in saudi
arabien herrschte wurden frauen und die
kunst aus dem öffentlichen raum verbannt
es fehlte jeder respekt vor den
schauspielerinnen
das war kein beruf den man sich für
seine tochter wünscht viele
schauspielerinnen ergriffen den beruf
weil sie geld brauchten
das hat sich aber sehr verändert mit der
vergabe von auszeichnungen versucht man
der schauspielkunst mehr respekt
entgegenzubringen
das ist im moment kein wagnis für die
hauptdarstellerin beispielsweise jetzt
in diesem film aufzutreten und sieht sie
in weiten teilen das filmische ohne
kopfbedeckung beispielsweise in ihrer
privaten kleidung
es ist kein wagnis es gibt im fernsehen
viele schauspielerinnen der beruf der
schauspielerin oder sängerin hat sich
etabliert
aber mit dem beruf einhergehen soziale
stigmatisierung dass schauspielerinnen
wie ärzte oder wie anwälte behandelt
würden
es ist wichtig diesen respekt für die
kunst in saudi arabien wieder zu
verankern und es gibt auch entsprechende
bewegungen auch ich fühle mich heute
anerkannt als filmemacherin jetzt wo
kinos wieder erlaubt sind kann ich um
eine bewilligung anfragen und in saudi
arabien drehen
es ist anders als bei mädchen war 2012
da fühlte ich mich bei öffentlichen
drews verletzlich verfolgt und unsicher
es konnte durchaus geschehen dass
tugendwächter und zwangen die
dreharbeiten abzubrechen
sie waren dazu zwar nicht befugt konnten
sich aber im öffentlichen raum gegen die
künstler durchsetzen
heute schützt der rechtsrahmen uns
künstler
wir können den kritikern entgegen treten
und unser recht einfordern
das ist wichtig wie kommt diese
veränderung zu staunenden ist er dann
sehr schnell vonstatten gegangen ja es
ging schnell
saudi arabien hat eine sehr junge
bevölkerung das durchschnittsalter liegt
unter 35 die junge generation ist
vertraut mit social media
sie sieht sich als teil der welt diese
veränderung entspricht ihrem wunsch nach
einem normalen leben sie wollen essen
gehen können musik hören viele mädchen
wollen keine arrangierte ehe sondern
ihren partner selber wählen
deshalb ist es wichtig kunst nach saudi
arabien zu bringen
für eine gesellschaft in der menschen
warum hört sich offen
und der bildung zugewandt sind braucht
es kunst musik film und literatur die
eine solche kultur eigentlich begründen
sie haben in vielen ihrer interviews
immer wieder betont sie kommen aus einem
liberalen elternhaus ihr vater ist kates
und dichter als sie hatten eine
affinität zur kunst
was bedeutet es in saudi arabien liberal
zu vereinen
konkret ich wuchs in einer kleinstadt
auf meine eltern sprechen auch kein
englisch aber sie waren gültig und
unterstützend ich stamme aus einer
großen familie mit zwölf geschwistern
meine eltern sagt mir nie dass meine
brüder mehr rechte hatten als ich sie
zwang mich auch nicht den schleier zu
tragen natürlich wünschten sie sich dass
sich ingenieure in oder ärztin werden
würde was man sich in der arabischen
welt wünscht wichtiger war der aspekt
dass wir zur mittelklasse gehörten und
wert auf bildung legten und einen beruf
erlernen sollten
gleichzeitig wurde in unserer familie
kunst hoch gehalten meine mutter sang
gern mein vater war ein dichter dass
saudi arabien meiner kindheit war sehr
konservativ und draußen begegnete ich
einer anderen realität in der schule
wurde uns beigebracht als frau mit
leiser stimme zu sprechen
frauen hatten unter sich zu bleiben und
durften keinen kontakt zu männern haben
heute aber werden mädchen ermuntert aus
diesen traditionellen rollen
auszubrechen
in der arbeitswelt lockern sich die
regeln so dass frauen nicht mehr nur mit
anderen frauen arbeiten dürfen
in den einkaufszentren arbeiten heute
viele frauen im verkauf und an der kasse
die die welt von water von dem mädchen
in ihrem ersten film dass ich das
fahrrad wünschte und es als unschicklich
galt die existiert so nicht mehr
vielleicht gibt es sie noch vereinzelt
in kleinstädten
dennoch hat sich viel bewegt und
verändert in der saudischen gesellschaft
[Musik]
aber bestimmte traditionelle werte die
etwa bestimmen wo man frauen treffen
darauf bestehen weiter es braucht zeit
diese zu verändern
nach der lockerung der regeln können
frauen heute alleine und ohne eine
bewilligung ihres männlichen vormunds
reisen sicherlich stellen sich aber
viele frauen im hinterkopf die frage ob
alleine zu reisen nicht unschädlich sei
es muss sich noch vieles ändern in der
art wie die frauen selbst die welt sehen
und wie sie durch ihre familien und die
gesellschaft ermächtigt werden ihr
eigenes leben zu leben
dabei geht es nicht nur um die regel
wichtiger noch ist es die im alltag
geltenden werte zu ändern damit frauen
mutig auftreten können ich wuchs in
einem rückwärtsgewandten saudi arabien
auf es gab so viele verbote nicht einmal
auto fahren durfte ich aber ich hatte
die unterstützung meiner familie
sie erlebte ihre liberalen werte und so
wurde ich zu der die ich heute bin
dies sind die werte um die wir uns im
interesse der menschen bemühen sollten
aber dafür braucht es zeit und viel
bildung stichwort veränderungen da setzt
ihr aktueller film auch anderen erzählen
sie die geschichte von maria einer
jungen ärztin die in einer saudischen
kleinstadt in einer notfallklinik
arbeitet und es nicht hinnimmt dass die
zufahrtsstraße in derart schlechtem
zustand ist so dass patienten muss sehr
umständlich dorthin gelangen können
um das zu ändern kandidiert sie für den
gemeinderat wir schauen uns jetzt einen
ausschnitt aus diesem film an
ja was heißt es denn eigentlich in saudi
arabien in einem gemeinderat zu arbeiten
welche kompetenzen hat ein gemeinderat
wie überall sonst auch braucht man ein
politisches programm
die ironie in die perfekte kandidatin
besteht darin dass sie über keine
politische erfahrung verfügt aber sehr
beherzt ist das ist das wichtigste
es braucht politiker mit herz und dem
willen zum erfolg
heute besitzen frauen in saudi arabien
zwar das aktive und passive wahlrecht
sie zögern aber im rampenlicht zu stehen
und sie fürchten sich vor dem scheitern
trotzdem sollten frauen kandidieren den
scheitern gehört zum weg es ist so
wichtig wie der erfolg
nur wenn wir uns zeigen gewöhnt man sich
daran frauen in führungsfunktionen zu
sehen als sie aus oder in der politik
auf gemeinde ebene oder als
filmemacherin man muss die initiative
ergreifen und sich aus der eigenen
komfortzone begeben
[Musik]
ihre erfahrung kommt von den social
media die auch in saudi arabien weit
verbreitet sind
das internet hat viele saudis sozial
enorm weitergebracht hier trifft man
sich um über dinge zu sprechen und zu
streiten
dieses im parlament für die frauen in
politik und öffentlichkeit sich zu
engagieren woher kommt das ist das von
oben herab
sozusagen als als jetzt ein teil der
veränderung die initiiert wird oder ist
es 111 im parlament dass aus den
familien und von den frauen selber kommt
sowohl als auch der nahe osten ist sehr
kompliziert und es lässt sich nur schwer
sagen welche faktoren genau zu den
veränderungen die wir heute sehen
geführt haben
viele gut ausgebildete junge saudi
frauen wollen bessere
arbeitsmöglichkeiten und ihre träume
verwirklichen
das bringt wandel wichtig ist aber auch
etwas anderes
frauen mit politischen funktionen werden
oft ernannt die breite bevölkerung setzt
ihr vertrauen nicht in frauen- und wählt
sie nicht in hohe ämter
dies zeigt sich auch in kuwait oder
ägypten wo frauen seit längerem über
politische erfahrung verfügen
das vertrauen in sie aber fehlt in
europa blickt ganz ähnliche probleme
gibt es auch im westen in den usa und in
europa hillary clinton ist ein
paradebeispiel dafür dass
hochqualifizierte frauen oft nicht ans
ziel kommen weil es viele vorurteile
gegenüber frauen in führungspositionen
gibt
trotzdem sollten wir uns bemühen diese
gemeinsame geschichte zu schaffen und
die erfolge der frauen zu feiern
so haben wir
saudi arabien jetzt die erste frau als
botschafterin und das auch noch in den
usa einer so wichtigen botschaft dies
ermutigt andere frauen sich ähnliches
auch zuzutrauen und den gedanken an den
erfolg zuzulassen
solche beispiele könnten frauen
ermutigen sind sie auch so ein
rollenvorbild sind inzwischen die
bekannteste saudische regisseurin
ich sehe mich nicht wirklich als vorbild
es würde mich aber freuen wenn ich die
menschen zu hause inspirieren könnte
ihre leidenschaft zu folgen
als ich mit dem filmemachen begann gab
es in saudi arabien noch keine
filmindustrie
man machte sich in den zeitungen lustig
über mich was soll das mit dieser
filmerei niemand nahm mich ernst ich
glaubte zu der zeit nicht an meinen
erfolg ich wurde nicht von der
vorstellung geleitet dass ich einmal als
filmemacherin in der schweiz interviews
führen würde und man im film zu bewerben
ich mache die filme weil mich das
erfüllt
es war fast wie eine therapie für mich
ich trete mit knappen budgets kurzfilme
und dokumentarfilme und versuchte
einfach eine geschichte zu erzählen
leben sie denn die solidarität unter
frauen es ist ein thema das sie auch in
ihrem neuen film auch ansprechen aber
bei ihnen persönlich erleben sie das
unterstützung von frauen
ich bekomme viel unterstützung von
frauen
diese solidarität unter frauen muss man
fliegen
es gilt eine gemeinsame geschichte zu
schaffen die wir weitergeben können
deshalb habe ich mich auch so gefreut
einen film über mary shelley zu machen
eigentlich unterscheidet uns alles sie
ist britin der film spielt in einer
anderen zeit
aber sie war eine der wenigen frauen die
zukunft romane geschrieben haben wo ihre
zeitgenossen jane austen zum beispiel
über eifersucht und liebe im häuslichen
rahmen schrieb sie aber griff ein
philosophisches thema auf und stellte
die anschauungen
religiösen vorstellungen ihrer zeit in
frage wir sollten das auch für uns in
anspruch nehmen
frankenstein wird oft als ein männer
buch angesehen
tatsächlich aber gründet es auf ihren
erfahrungen als frau der schwierigen
beziehung zu ihrem mann einem verlorenen
kind daraus entwickelte sich das monster
wir müssen ähnliches wagen und unsere
geschichte in die eigene hand nehmen
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir uns
gegenseitig unterstützen
ob als führungsperson oder als
produzentin und danach streben diese
kultur der solidarität da wo sie noch
nicht besteht aufzubauen und zu pflegen
lassen sie uns trotzdem noch über die
männer sprechen insbesondere über die
jungen männer
sie haben es vorhin schon angesprochen
was die hälfte der bevölkerung in saudi
arabien ist unser 30 welche
einstellungen haben denn heute junge
männer viele von ihnen gerade aus der
oberschicht studieren ja auch im ausland
kommen dann zurückkommen die mit
veränderten einstellungen zurück oder
hatten die einfach eine gute zeit im
ausland und übernehmen dann trotzdem
wieder die konservativen ansichten ihrer
eltern ein studium im ausland verändert
einen die studienjahre machen einen
zudem der mann ist mit einer solchen
bildungs erfahrung wählen junge leute
sorgfältig aus der tradition aus sie
wollen ein normales leben wo
insbesondere das geschlechterverhältnis
ausgeglichener ist
ich betrachte mich als feministin
aber in meinen filmen verkörpern die
männer nicht das böse schlechthin
der vater im film ist seinen kindern
gegenüber zurückhaltend freundlich und
unterstützen
er hat eigene träume es ist sehr wichtig
diese art der männlichkeit
nahen osten zu würdigen und in filmen
oder auch in der popkultur prominent
darzustellen
im nahen osten erschöpfte sich die rolle
des vaters im fernsehen darin die
töchter zu schlagen und zu unterdrücken
die ständige darstellung dieser gewalt
produzierte eine vorstellung von
männlichkeit der es nachzueifern galt
dieses bild entspricht aber nicht der
realität natürlich gibt es das an
verschiedenen orten in sexistischen
kulturen
es existiert aber genauso gibt es männer
wie mein vater die gütig und
unterstützend sind von denen aber
niemand spricht weil dies nicht
dramatisch genug ist das hilft dem
sensationsteam wenn der vater der
familientyrann ist deshalb ist es
wichtig auch die art männer zu würdigen
das ist das ideal auf der einen seite
die realität auf der anderen seite
gerade läuft ein schweizer dokfilm der
heißt seit ebay und der wird bei uns
heftig diskutiert es dokumentiert die
heimliche flucht einer jungen frau aus
saudi arabien die der enge und der
bestimmung über sie entkommen will und
man sagt sie seien jährlich rund 1000
frauen die aus saudi arabien flüchten
können sie das nachvollziehen jetzt zu
einem zeitpunkt wo doch alles auf
öffnung und veränderung stellt können
sie mir bitte fragen zu meinem vielen
stellen ich bin nicht hier um über die
filme die haltungen anderer zu sprechen
ich bin filmemacherin und ich leiste
meinen beitrag zur veränderung über
meine filme
sie sind mein ausdrucksmittel und mein
film dreht sich um eine junge saudis in
die versucht ihre stimme zu finden
natürlich werde ich ihn in saudi arabien
zeigen er war unter anderem im programm
neue medien
es ist ein film voller humor musik und
herz mir ist es wichtig das publikum
abzuholen
ich wuchs in einem saudi arabien ohne
kino und ohne publikum auf meine filme
sollen unterhalten sein spaß machen und
eine geschichte erzählen
wenn man die menschen erreichen berühren
und sie wirklich verändern will muss man
sie unterhalten
das ist meine haltung zum kino das ist
meine haltung zum wandel und es ist
meine haltung zum leben
am lotter confrontation ich bin keine
streitlustige person
ich will die menschen nicht aus ihrer
komfortzone bugsieren
die rolle der kunst besteht für mich
darin eine atmosphäre zu schaffen in der
dinge geschehen können das heißt
kunstwort für sie keine politische
relevanz sicher hat kunst politischer
relevanz aber kunst ist nicht aktivismus
kunst ist unterhaltsam berührt die seele
und schafft im besten fall eine
entspannte atmosphäre in der menschen
etwas lernen
das ist sehr wichtig erst musik
literatur und philosophie schaffen die
für veränderungen notwendige entspannung
offenheit und toleranz durch sie
erlangen menschen die fähigkeit sich der
welt gegenüber zu öffnen und zu lernen
meine rolle als künstlerin besteht darin
humor spaß und musik beizutragen und
damit hoffentlich die menschen zu
berühren
das funktioniert nicht dadurch dass man
sie drangsaliert veränderung ist eine
heikle sache in einem gereizten klima
klammert man sich umso mehr an seine
werte ich kann das sehr gut
nachvollziehen aus meinem aus meiner
eigenen arabischen biografie wie
sensitiv das alles ist aber diese filme
machen sie ja für ein internationales
publikum das heißt ein westliches
publikum wird ihnen möglicherweise
vorwerfen er ist zu wenig kritisch ag zu
wenig weit er hat nicht die sprache
eines verständnisses von wirklich
veränderungen herbeizuführen wenn sie
aber einen arabischen und speziellen
saudi arabischen publikum vorführen hat
das eine ganz andere
wird das ein ganz anderes echo auslösen
wie gehen sie mit dieser gratwanderung
zwischen den kulturen
[Musik]
alle meine filme thematisieren wichtiges
auf lustige und unterhalt
natürlich hoffe ich dass sie zu hause in
den kinos gezeigt und gelobt werden ich
möchte dass viele mädchen sich in der
rolle von mariam sehen und viele männer
sich in den vater hineinversetzen können
selbstverständlich wünsche ich mir auch
dass der film in zürich gezeigt wird als
filmemacherin träume ich davon ein
breites publikum zu erreichen
es ist keine einfache sache
ein drehbuch zu schreiben das der welt
eine lokale situation authentisch
vermittelt und humorvoll über eine
fremde und schwer zugängliche kultur
berichtet es ist sehr wichtig
situationen zu zeigen die gehaltvoll und
gleichzeitig authentisch sind
sie wurden 2018 ernannt in einem in
einen rad wo es um kultur geht von der
saudischen regierung was ich die auf
ihre aufgabe in diesem kulturrat
ich versuche einer jungen generation von
filmemachern türen zu öffnen
es gibt in saudi arabien keine filmische
infrastruktur selbst für internationale
produzenten ist es schwierig in saudi
arabien filme zu drehen weil man keine
entsprechend ausgebildeten leute findet
noch schwieriger ist es für junge
regisseure die notwendigen mittel für
viel mitzubekommen die außerhalb des
heimmarkt gezeigt werden sollen
ich unterstütze sie bei der suche nach
produzenten oder der entwicklung ihrer
ideen der mittelbeschaffung oder der
arbeit am drehbuch riskieren sie nicht
gleichzeitig aber auch ihre
unabhängigkeit sie haben jetzt diesen
film gemacht seine deutsch saudische
produktion haben sie mit den behörden
zusammengearbeitet
jeder der in saudi arabien arbeitet muss
das drehbuch einreichen um eine
drehgenehmigung zu bekommen
mir ist es wichtig in saudi arabien zu
drehen weil sonst niemand diese welt zu
sehen bekommt durch die arbeit mit
laiendarstellern strebe ich eine echte
intimität an
ich möchte einen saudi arabien weit weg
von jeder politik und allen schlagzeilen
zeigen
also ja auch ich muss ein gesuch
einreichen
saudi arabien ist eine konservative
gesellschaft all along wenn ich dort
filme wo sich die grenzen kennen und
bestimmte dinge respektieren das tue ich
gerne weil ich so zu hause gehört werde
und hoffentlich den blickwinkel etwas
erweitern kann
ich empfinde ihre fragen als aggressiv
und anklagend eine solche haltung führt
dazu dass künstler wie ich die saudi
arabien verändern möchten dort keine
anerkennung finden
das ist eine schwierige situation
gehaltvolle filme die ein breites
publikum erreichen entstehen nicht
einfach so deshalb ist es wichtig die
kunst vor ort in saudi arabien zu
fördern um die liberalen und
progressiven strömungen zu unterstützen
eine kurze frage sind schon fast am
schluss
sie leben und arbeiten vor allem in den
usa haben sie eigentlich heimweh
vermissen sie etwas haben
natürlich vermisse ich vieles ich
besuche meine mutter die in meiner
kleinen heimatstadt wohnt ich vermisse
das essen meine schwester meine
verwandten
das ist man zu hause selbstverständlich
vermisse ich solche dinge gut ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei ihnen
ich habe ein mann zu sein gesund wir
bleiben noch etwas beim thema saudi
arabien und die frauen was macher liefer
ist eine britische stylistin und
filmemacherin mit saudischen wurzeln
2009 10 geht sie zurück in ihr
geburtsland um auszuloten ob sie dort
für immer leben könnte der film inside
digital.de arabia dokumentiert ihren
kampf mit den regeln in der
öffentlichkeit und gibt seltene private
einblicke in das leben einer saudischen
mittelstandsfamilie
[Musik]